what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and today i am
going to be reacting
to this guy called darius he has a video
called destroy her ego i thought
this looked fun so i decided i would
have react to it
for the first time with all of you
before i start if you guys like my
channel do not forget to subscribe
leave a like on the video and let me
know in the comments if you think that
this like
pickup stuff works all right i'm about
to
destroy her ego this looks fun
really great wholesome listen like the
video share the video
i appreciate all the support that i've
been getting from you guys i do just
do these dating coaches have successful
relationships i mean i i'd imagine they
probably sleep with a lot of girls fine
but like successful long-term
relationships
let me know you man stay positive
continue to take the red pill this
segment is going to be about
knocking a woman off her pedestal
destroying her ego
something every man must do if you're
still dealing women from time to time
every what a woman's ego
is is huge it's her head is in the
clouds she's on a different planet
the reason why because for years her
whole life she's been told she's
attractive she looks good that
she's just beautiful goddess she's this
queen
she must be humbled she it's not true
i mean from some yeah but like
i posted a video the other day i had
like five comments asking if i was
pregnant
i'm not must be brought down to earth
so in this segment i'm giving you four
tips
what things that you should do from time
to time
to just humble her bring her down to
bring her down earth
let her know hey you're not the best
thing since sliced bread
i got four tips today and these are no
particular order
uh of significance number one
you got to tell it hey text him one day
hey this is this isn't going to work out
good luck to you she'll be uh oh wait
wait
what's going on you know she's going to
want to know why
you're you're dumping her you're leaving
her you're tossing to the trash
simply because every man she's dealt
with and been with
she's left them she's dumped them she's
rejected them so when you tell her this
out of the blue
or just anytime she does something
foolish
you know what it does it sends off an
alarm in her head
and it humbles her and says hey this guy
has value
i have value i can get rid of you
anytime i want to
this is must be done you must be
ready and willing at any moment of the
day any day any hour
to hey tell her hey even if you're not
if you even if you don't mean it
tell the haters not again this might
work in the short term but are you guys
looking for short-term
unsuccessful relationships are you
looking for marriages
because if you're married 20-plus years
you can
break up with your wife every time [ __ ]
happens
i'm gonna work out good luck see how she
reacts
number two give it a dick and don't
touch her back
this destroys her ego you know why
because
every her ego is attached to her vagina
when you [ __ ] her you take her soul you
take everything
she has anything of value everything of
value
is all invested in her vagina and this
is why
i always recommend to girls like if you
can
wait because
you're one your value decreases to guys
like the more guys you've slept with
and two like protect your heart honestly
so when you [ __ ] her and you don't text
and call her back and
like a semp like a mangina and chase her
down you know what that does
it sends an alarm off in her head and
says hey what's going on i mean i gave
him some [ __ ] he's supposed to be
attached she's supposed to be hooked
i think women just feel used actually
but no
you as a man are not hooked you're
giving her dick and not texting her back
guarantee you she's gonna want to know
uh you know what happened was was my
[ __ ] not good
what's going on this knocks her off her
pedestal because you're not chasing her
just because she gave you some [ __ ] one
time
number three what every woman usually
does
when she calls you when she texts you
wait hours to text her back
i mean hours sometimes a full day if you
have to
you know what this does this shows her
hey you are no significance in my life
you know i'm not gonna be at your beck
and call i'm not gonna text you back
whenever you want me to so this this
once again sends the alarm off in her
head i mean this works if the girl's
really
interested in you but not all guys
not every not all guys you're super
interested in from the get go
it says hey you know it makes you
mysterious as a man
because she's gonna wonder all
throughout the day this is how you get a
woman hooked as well
she's gonna wonder what's what's going
on with uh so-and-so what is he doing
what's going on i mean she's gonna want
to know what you're up to
so you text her out of the blue hey you
know i've been busy i've been doing this
this and that
you always have to seem busy you have to
seem aloof when you're dealing with
these women
because once they know you're at their
beck and call
and you aren't a busy man they're going
to lose interest
so you must be mysterious
pop in pop out
pop back in that's is that easy you must
be aloof uh number four
as like i said in previous previous
video i think this is a a
huge one tell her she's fat
i mean this is the number one biggest
thing
the most important one you can do with
the most significance
if you tell a woman she's fat her whole
life
revolves around her image how she looked
that's what that's what a woman is from
the makeup from the clothes she wears
uh oh my god this guy's a monster
thing so when you slush
i don't think i was meant to watch this
i've never had a guy tell me that i've
had the internet tell me that tell her
she's fat
do these things i mean when she asks you
how do i look in this dress
uh you you look kind of fat
or tell her hey you can fat you need to
go work out go to the gym
go do something this will humble her
and let her know hey you're not the best
thing since sliced bread you're not the
best looking woman on the planet you not
that attractive
it will humble her bring her down earth
knock her off that pedestal another
thing is
then you can do if you guys are just
hanging out maybe watching tv or
uh or maybe out and about if she has a
girlfriend uh
any female friends you know tell her oh
so-so
looks kind of cute katie shaquita or or
brittany or sarah
tell her hey her your friends look kind
of cute this will
instantly knock her ego off
deflater ego you guys have to remember
these like literally
the point of the internet is to get
views like literally to get views
and if you want to be in a toxic
relationship sure
do this that's a great idea but
again i'm i'm just a long-term thinker
my dad would not to my to her face
call my mom fat bring her down earth
cause she did you know what this does
this says hey
he's not that you know he's not that
into me my other friends look good
you know i must look like trash you must
do these things
also if you guys are sitting at home
watching a movie or
hey you know she likes women like to
watch reality shows or
the view or whatever daytime talk show
or some show
it's you know it's a lot of attractive
women in movies if you
watching the vh1 uh you know watching
vh1 or
basketball wives tell her hey that
female looks pretty good
she looks cute she's attractive i [ __ ]
her i have sex with her
this will instantly deflate her ego and
and
knock and humble her because she one
thing she has to realize is
you're not the the best thing since
sliced bread you're not the most
attractive woman on the planet
i'm not chasing you there's plenty other
fish out there in the sea
you men must humble these women because
their egos
are inflated by men they get constant
text messages
and inboxes from their
social medias telling hey you're so
beautiful can i take you out
she rarely ever if if never she she's
never gotten
her ego deflated she's never gotten told
she's fat
she's never gotten told that's not true
other women can be pretty mean
and hey you need to go work out
again i think this is the feminism
culture
like the everybody's beautiful
like some girls haven't but
i think a lot of that is rooted in
insecurity your friend is attractive
that woman on tv
that vh1 reality show that you that you
like watching oh my god
that woman is a lot more attractive you
i [ __ ] her she's not being used to told
these things
she's not being used uh ever until man
rejecting her she's always used to
leaving first she's left every man she's
been with she's rejected every man she's
been with so one thing you need to do
is if she gets out of line you say hey
this is not gonna work out
uh good luck i guarantee you she'd be
running back to you
okay i get the idea i mean guys
again we're just gonna go back to
short term sure this stuff might work
but what's your goal
is your goal to hook up with as many
girls as possible
to get the quality of women that are
gonna like put up with that sort of
thing
i mean if that's your goal then go for
it but it's
not something i'd recommend for happy
and healthy relationships but let me
know if you guys think this stuff works
in the comments do not forget to like
comment and subscribe share this video
with a friend
and yeah let me know what you think of
the comments bye guys